well
i may not have
a sign of victory for those who believe
in freedom but at least have some
catharsis here's a story from
timcast.com
democratic national committee tells
unvaccinated employees they face
termination employees of the dnc are
expected to return to in-person work on
january 3rd 2022. i find that really
funny because of all of the people who
work anywhere you wouldn't expect to
find people who aren't vaccinated
working for the dnc but apparently there
are and now those people who have
given their work towards empowering the
dnc are going to lose their jobs
now look i don't want to revel in
anybody losing their job i don't like
the dnc i don't want the rnc for that
matter but these are the people who vote
for this stuff they support the stuff
they actively work for the dnc to
support this and now they're coming to
them saying well you're going to lose
your job now unless you fall in line and
they're like but but i don't want to
fall in line oh congratulations on what
you asked for you get what you get what
you wish for you know i'm sorry good
comrade you're going to have to take
this one for the team
i'll be able to step back i'm sorry if
trump had won the election we'd be in
the same situation right now he was just
as authoritative and ignorant wow he was
just he rushed that vaccine out he was
going to do it anyway how is that
authority because they let they're
letting the cdc run the show right now
and he was letting fauci run the show
when he was in office so i don't blame
the the democrats it's just the idiocy
of authoritarianism and ignorant
authoritarianism that's true trump let
fouchy do all this stuff trump was on
board with 15 days of spread that was a
trump plan
and then he could have he could have
came you know he did try coming out a
few months later being like we should
reopen and here's my plan but i don't
have the authority to mandate the states
the states do this the states were doing
it not the federal government well now
joe biden is doing it so at the very
least i can say this trump did let fauci
run run afoul and run amok joe biden is
still worse but yeah you know if trump
was gonna have fouchy staying in there
and now he's coming out like i should
have fired the guy yeah you should have
fight a lot of people but he didn't i
don't think it'd be the same i don't
think there'd be mandates the mandates
would be at the state level but not the
federal level trump would not come out
and say we are going to require all
people are mandated to do this yeah
you're right i don't want to make an
assumption like that i will say though
i'm willing to bet if trump did you'd
have a large portion of trump supporters
being like yes
absolutely trump is doing the right
thing by mandating this well it's very
interesting to see a lot of very
prominent blue check mark individuals
who previously said that they would
never take the trump scene right the
trump vaccine who are now saying you
must take this vaccine and it's
mandatory when trump was the one who
rushed emergency authorization for it
he's the one that literally on national
television wanted the vaccine to be
called the trump scene and now he's
making some very interesting statements
i mean he he was a big pusher of this he
was a big proponent of this and this
needs to be acknowledged a lot of people
are very distrustful of him because of
this but now he's making some very
interesting statements and i don't know
if he's just trying to play up to the
popular base if he really means this
because he was a big on full-on vaccine
supporter but now he's saying that the
third booster shot is about money and
not about health this is not me saying
of this donald trump saying
what he said recently about the booster
shots that that people are being
mandated that now two million people in
israel have lost their vaccine status
because of because they didn't take the
third child i think trump's wrong though
i don't think the third booster shot is
about money
i think all of it is about money i do
think however you know you look at the
the expose from project veritas what do
we learn from these three scientists at
pfizer they actually think the vaccine
is safe and effective and works however
they do add if you've already had covet
your natural immunity is probably better
well there you go
the question then becomes if we're going
to have that conversation is it
get covered to avoid covet because that
doesn't quite make sense but if you did
accidentally already get it then you
should be left alone outside of all that
i think we're falling into a trap on the
mandates in general we shouldn't be
talking about there should be no
mandates no papers please none of that
we gotta be careful about that i mean
there's some studies showing that people
with natural immunity could have
immunity for the rest of their lives uh
that's a lot better than the waning
immunity for five to six months
comparatively to the vaccine which again
these fiser scientists are openly
admitting but we should be having a
national conversation about this
they didn't say it was waning they just
said natural immunity was potentially
better yeah this is tough stuff man i
look i read a really great article from
yahoo that basically said here's a study
from cleveland i think it was a
cleveland clinic and like university of
washington or something as well as an
israeli study saying that natural
immunity is particularly effective
however they did mention one smaller
study which you know take into
consideration from i can't remember
where this one was from but it said that
uh natural immunity didn't have any like
they didn't see a discernible difference
between that in the vaccine so i'll put
it this way look
we shouldn't be getting f we're falling
into that trap i don't want to fall into
that trap i don't want to i don't want
to sit here and have a conversation
about you know waning this or natural
meaning that no mandates
none you shouldn't have to show your
papers to enter a building i don't care
what for because what's going to happen
is if we keep trying to reframe it in
this way and that's where the debate's
being pulled probably on purpose then we
end up with social credit systems either
way that path leads to two doors social
credit system with exemptions and social
credit systems how about we just say no
i think the social credit system is
going to be put in through an economic
crash but that i could save that
conversation for a little bit later but
the another thing to highlight about
this uh uh project veritas video is they
have chris cross a pfizer senior
associate scientist saying quote i work
for an evil corporation our organization
is run on covid money uh that's not me
saying that that's chris cross pfizer
senior associate scientist
so i i mean project veritas is releasing
a lot of these videos but let's not get
pulled into that like i think this is
really important to recognize the
motives of a major corporation
especially when you have you know
government mandates there's a major
profit motive in there but again that's
why the conversation should always be
pulled away from that
and straight into hey no mandates
none
you gotta wonder though is pfizer
incentivizing the government to push it
the vaccine i remember when they're like
who's going to get the contract and
you're like oh the contract right is
that what this is hey pfizer got the
contract and so did mederano they got a
contract too there's a contract for like
it's that
it's very interesting to see a lot of
attacks on johnson and johnson uh and
you don't see the same kind of level of
scrutiny against moderna and pfizer
that's weird and that is very weird to
see because you know johnson johnson is
not an mrna vaccine right it's an uh
it's a it's a different one it's a
adenovirus dna vaccination yeah yeah so
so
you know why can we have a real
discussion about one corporation but not
another one from what i know about these
uh uh old older vaccines they provoke a
natural immune response that's the point
you give a little bit your body body's
like whoa the virus is here let's create
a real immune response then you have
natural immunity the rna ones i think
however maybe it's the same are you sure
because i think they only protect
against one of the spike proteins or a
couple of spiked proteins on the outer
layer of the there's like the attenuated
uh virus vaccine i think it's called
where they give you either like weakened
dead or you know just a small amount of
live vaccine i think the george
washington smallpox inoculations was
just a very small amount they would
prick you with so your body would defeat
it then build antibodies and then what
mrna does is it programs themselves to
produce spike proteins which then get
attacked and so in the veritas video the
physio scientist is saying
that natural immunity has antibodies to
multiple parts of the virus whereas the
vaccine is just the spike protein still
look
it it's interesting to see what i get
out of the veritas stuff is that you
have these scientists who are straight
up saying that it's money you know that
natural immunity is good and it's money
but again
we we need to just be focused on the
mandates and i'm going to keep pulling
it back because
mandate the end result of that
conversation will always be a social
credit system it's not even mandates
it's basic human rights tim yes i get it
man but you guys keep trying to pull the
conversation back into we should have
been arguing about how we should support
the man no not at all no absolutely not
when the conversation is natural
immunity you're basically saying
exceptions to to that conference to to
mandates james lindsay has a tweet where
he said eventually when the mandates
start failing when they're not working
the conversation will shift to some kind
of exemption some reasonable alternative
that still has mandates
we
cannot
have a conversation consistently just
going back into the same thing it's it's
frustrating because it's such an easy
and obvious trap
we get it they make vaccines talk to
your doctor
don't support the policy of
authoritarians period i don't care to
talk about the rest of the stuff because
it's the same trick you get everybody
watching the show telling their friends
look look with respect to james o'keefe
i think it's a big story that shows you
what these people think of this company
but i we got to be careful about a
conversation that says people who have
natural immunity should be allowed
exemptions in the vaccine mandates no no
no no show me your papers please period
that's my hard line yeah i agree with
you there's no reason that you need a
permission slip for the government to go
to the supermarket or to get a haircut
that's an absolutely ridiculous huge
step by government that they're totally
abusing in an absolutely non-scientific
way in in a way that absolutely doesn't
justify it and there's elements of this
official story that people use to kind
of back this up and i think that's why
some people chip away at the official
narrative but i think the people who
chip away the official narrative aren't
saying that the the the mandates are
good i think that the mandates are
absolutely inhuman i i think
the government literally creating new
hoops every six months saying you need
to do this in order to comply i mean
israelis is the big ask yeah the
israelis are getting a huge rude
awakening this is the this is the big
ass
where they say everyone's mandated a
vaccine plus boosters uh okay well you
can also do negative testing and
antibody testing it's like no no i'm not
big ass i'm not playing that game
none none of this they they have
implemented so many changes over covid
they called the new normal that have not
been reversed and that's what we need to
be talking about they use the vaccine
because they know regular people
typically trust their doctors sometimes
people have bad doctors they know
regular people support vaccination and
that is the attack vector because then
you can get regular people maybe some of
these parents maybe some of these people
question their bank account to hear a
story where they say a group of people
are saying vaccine bad they don't want
to get it and they're like that's weird
vaccines are typically good the
narrative needs to be no no vaccine's
fine you you you go to your doctor you
figure out your own health decisions
mandate by government authority
show me your papers bad you know this is
bringing me to jacobsen versus
massachusetts 1905 supreme court case
where a guy did not want to get the
smallpox vaccine because of his
religious rights and the government
eventually went to the supreme court
they decided you have to get the vaccine
smallpox is too dangerous so now we're
in a similar situation is coveted as
dangerous as smallpox
is it that kind of danger that's the
question
no i i don't think it is i i understand
the precedent in that i think the
question is when do we allow the
government to mandate you show your
papers you want to talk about saying
people need to be vaccinated to go to
school i've had that conversation look
over a long period of time there was
legislation scientific studies long-term
health effects were reported and we said
here's what we think about this vaccine
it's good okay we hereby vote for for
our representative representatives all
kind of agree we're all in favor of this
okay we're gonna require vaccinations at
school so we all shake hands and move on
with our lives this is something else
this is in new york city if you want to
go to a restaurant you need an id
you need an up-to-date passport card
this isn't about the precedent of
vaccines that's what keeps happening
every time the conversation is being
pulled back into other unrelated things
instead of saying why are they demanding
my papers why is joe biden ruling by
edict and said once again it falls back
to i wonder what the precedent is of
vaccines and then you see in the media
we we mandate mmr vaccines why are you
so concerned i'm not concerned about the
mrna vaccines actually i think they're
quite brilliant when i read about the
adenovirus dna vaccine johnson jets i
was like wow they did tremendous
research on this stuff great government
should be demanding my papers joe biden
shouldn't be enforcing by edict they
shouldn't be setting osha rules by
decree the supreme court should not be
overruled by joe biden on the cd with
his eviction moratorium the legislation
should not be bypassed by biden the
governors should not be murdering people
this is the stuff that's getting washed
away because the conversation keeps
drifting back but the argument against
that is sometimes a governor has to
ruled out by decree like abraham lincoln
uh you know repealing habeas corpus but
for the civil war in order to fight a
war properly suspending it and then
eventually bring it back but suspending
habeas corpus like getting rid of human
rights and
if they believe someone believes that
the virus is that dangerous as like a
war it's like a viral war that we're
fighting then then they will support the
authoritarian we recognize and a lot of
people do a lot of people don't that we
recognize a great moral evil
in slavery
and the good abraham lincoln did in
fighting a war that kept the country
unified and then ended slavery
contributed to the end of slavery the
emancipation proclamation there's a lot
of complicated politics involved in what
his motives were ending slavery was
extremely popular in the north and there
were a lot of activists fighting on that
moral ground but for a lot of people it
was wealth loss of access to cash and
the moral issues weren't as big
slavery was was the prime component of
what was driving states apart but then
of course there are other people who are
concerned about other issues several
states succeeded not because of slavery
but because of the the the battle of
fort sumter when they saw what was going
on with the fighting they said this
union is too much for us virginia split
in half west virginia and virginia so
anyway the point is
we we recognize abraham lincoln and we
recognize he did bad things
we don't like the bad things he did we
like the good things he did so when we
look now and we're watching a government
like joe biden say i believe in in my
heart of hearts i must do these things
to you for your own good i say nah
because what he's doing is more in line
with buchanan than abraham lincoln he's
ripping this country to shreds he's
telling people you're complicit if you
don't support what my economic plan what
does that have to do with the with the
emergency decreases in acting on
mandates saying that osha now has a rule
where if your business has 100 or more
employees we are mandating by decree
that is that is a well above and beyond
anything a good president would be doing
it is ripping this country to shreds not
healing it not fixing it and not
fighting to preserve it
but here's the reason that i don't
necessarily care that the conversation
gets splintered about mandates it keeps
going back to you know efficacy and all
this other stuff about vaccines is as
far as i can tell there are two
different camps of people on this issue
there are people that are very much
anti-mandate and there are people that
are pro-mandate i don't know how to have
a conversation anymore with the people
that are pro-mandate i literally don't
know how to get through to them because
they can justify it every single it
doesn't matter what kind of argument you
present to them they'll say that it's
more dangerous they'll say cove is so
dangerous we have to do that they say oh
well it's going to get back to normal we
just got to wait for it to get back to
normal and then you can say okay well
that's why we don't take our shoes off
when we go to airport security anymore
and they say that
there's no getting through to them you
don't but you don't need to we don't
we're not trying to tell those people to
come back to reality i'm trying to tell
the people who are in reality stop
sending the conversation to unrelated
issues
stop sending the conversation to medical
issues over policy issues
if people want to go to the doctor
if people want to go to a parking lot
for a pop-up vaccination center i don't
care that's their business not mine if
the government wants to rule by decree
and force people to undergo medical
procedures i got a very serious problem
with this having a debate over efficacy
and things like that is distracting and
pulling people towards a conversation
where we accept a social credit system
with exemptions
no freedom decentralization a republic
electoral college all the good stuff the
founding fathers played forth and then
all of the amazing amendments that we've
enacted but we're being ripped to shreds
we're trying to have a conversation with
those who are in reality saying keep the
conversation on the mandates the people
who are pro-mandate will never change
that they're authoritarians they love
the mandates they've always loved it
they celebrate auntie for burning down
people's buildings they believe whatever
the authority tells them you're not
getting through to them but if if the
people in reality stop focusing on the
mandates what happens
okay you guys win
if you've had natural if you have
natural immunity or negative tests we're
now going to allow you to come to these
stores and then they go we did it we won
mandate now permanent no
no mandate bad i wouldn't comply with
that if they said if they made that rule
change i would be like um still i'm not
showing any kind of paperwork because if
i want to go to the supermarket grocery
store bowling alley movie theater i'm
gonna do what i want without having to
be checked for my medical records and my
medical history it's just
absurd and i think every element of the
story deserves to be kind of talked
about considered broken down but i agree
with you the bigger element here is that
human rights are being violated people
are getting discriminated against
people's livelihoods are being taken
away from them because they're not
licking the boot of big government and
and that's the issue here it does need
to be addressed and we need to stick to
the core values of personal liberty
freedom and personal responsibility
for all the individuals involved here
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you